[Music]
holly is with us holly is in charleston
west virginia hi holly how are you
i'm great how are you better than i
deserve what's up
all right so i made my husband watch
black borrowed future about a month ago
and he's finally on board with paying
off our student loans together we have
about 350 000. good lord who's the
doctor or lawyer
we're both physician assistants yeah
okay well that's good you're both pa so
what do you what's your household income
uh about 200. good good okay and today
is actually his birthday he turned 42
today
yeah he's kind of concerned that he
doesn't have any retirement or [ __ ] at
all he should be yeah yes so he's
willing to put some away for that i was
wondering
no you're broke
yeah you're 350 000 in debt right you're
talking about being an investor you're
broke
yeah
and i've got about thirty thousand in my
retirement so do i need to put that on
hold and just through yes that with
everything you put your life on hold
you don't need to go on vacation or go
out to eat you don't need to eat
anything but beans and rice you need to
live off of coupons and stay at home and
play board games and work all the time
as much hours as you can get and you
need to pay this off in three years
all right three years when you're 45 i
want you to call me and tell me you're
debt free
all right yeah well thank you so much
can you do that
i think we can he's uh he's working two
jobs i can work extra and we've been
doing the every dollar budget for about
a month and we've already paid off 3
500. so i think we're right on track i
just wasn't sure what to do no you're
not on track no no no i'm sorry you're
not on track you need to pay off 8 000 a
month
oh okay
you make 200 000 a year
yep
okay a hundred thousand dollars a year
for three years and you're done
yeah we've got four kids and a child
support too so there's some other
payments in there but
uh we can definitely save more than we
have been yeah stop all your retirement
temporarily
stop all spending temporarily
and attack this like your house is on
fire the faster you get out the more
likely you are to get out and the more
wealthy you'll build for retirement
all right that's what i needed to hear
thank you so much
thank you this is the ramsay show she's
not gonna do that open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
but we'll do some form of it and
hopefully we'll get it dialed in and get
there yeah how fast can i get off the
phone with dave because it's making me
really nervous